what a way to start pride month wow
I think the libs are focusing especially
on the most conservative or open to
conservative kind of platforms and
industries in particular because they
know they've already got the the ones
that have gone far left
so there are some places Twitter now
says okay we're going to be open to
conservatives I think the libs are going
to Target that even I think about sports
the only sport I like is Major League
Baseball
it's the only I don't even follow it in
recent years I tried to cancel my MLB TV
subscription I just don't really know
how to do it so I think I still
subscribe but but after they embraced
BLM I said okay I'm done with MLB I'm
not watching baseball this year and that
was some years ago now but baseball
remains pretty conservative it's
America's pastime it's a complicated
traditional sport it's one that Still
Remains a favorite of that most
derided hated group in society
straight white males we still sort of
like baseball it's it's a sport that
still has manly normal guys of of all
backgrounds playing it and so the libs
are really focusing on that and you saw
this with the Toronto Blue Jays you saw
this with Anthony bass who came out and
he he made a post that was critical of
pride
and he felt the weight of the liberal
establishment on him and I'm sorry to
say he just came out and apologized
I recognized yesterday I made a post
that was hurtful to the pride Community
which includes friends of mine and close
family members of mine Pride community
and I'm truly sorry for that
um I just spoke with my teammates and
shared with them my actions yesterday I
apologize with them and as right now I'm
using the Blue Jays resources to better
educate myself to make better decisions
moving forward the ballpark is for
everybody we include all fans at the
Ballpark and we want to welcome
everybody that's all I have to say thank
you
pathetic
what the hell is the pride Community
when did we start using that phrase The
Pride Community we're not even referring
now to guys who are a little light in
the loafers or lesbians or anything no
it's the pride Community I've said it
before I'll say it again I'm from New
York I lived in La for a long time I'm a
graduate of the gayest University in the
history of the world
a disproportionate number of my friends
and loved ones have some Divergent
eccentric sexual identities okay
I don't think any of them even the ones
who are
engaging in liberace-like Behavior I
don't think any of them would ever
describe themselves as members of The
Pride Community I don't think they would
take that identity on themselves
pride is the deadliest of the seven
deadly sins
Pride goeth Before Destruction in a
haughty spirit before a fall Pride this
Rainbow Coalition is a denial of reality
it's it's extraordinarily corrosive
to society it's it's offensive to all
people of decency
the vast majority of Americans
regardless of their sexual desires or
eccentricities don't want to be
inundated with with three-month-old
rainbow onesies when they walk into
Target and yet
uh relatively manly normal guy playing
America's favorite pastime albeit up in
America's Top Hat up there in Canada
even those guys now have to bend the
knee for what for what man right now go
to expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show
let me ask you something when you use
the restroom you always close the door
behind you right you don't want random
passersby looking in on you so why would
you let people look in on you when you
go online
using the internet without expressvpn is
like going to the restroom and not
closing the door okay I love expressvpn
I'm a total Luddite so I barely know how
to use any technology but it's so easy
to use even I can use it you just
download it one click of a button on
your cell phone on your laptop on your
on your iPad on whatever you want I can
say with full confidence expressvpn is
the best VPN on the market here's why
number one expressvpn doesn't log your
online activity they even developed a
trusted server technology that makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all number two speed
expressvpn does not slow down your user
experience you can stream HD videos with
zero buffering number three expressvpn
is incredibly easy to use
it's that one button you're done you're
good to go if you're like me you believe
your online activity is your business
use our link expressvpn.com Michael
Knowles show today get three months free
in a one-year package
expresvpn.com Michael Knowles show
expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show this
reaction from Anthony bass here it
it it makes me check in on myself
it makes me check in I don't mean just
to castigate this guy but it reminds me
before the passion of Our Lord
Saint Peter spokesman of the Apostles
first among the apostles he says oh I
would never deny you Lord
and his Lord guy who he knows is God the
son who he has seen transfigured on a
mountain
he says oh Peter you're going to deny me
three times before the grows and
Peter says no I wouldn't I would never
do that what are you talking about
that's crazy I I would never do that
thing and then what happens
the minute the pressure gets hot even
Peter denies it
for what what was the post that this guy
Anthony
put out this is the post for pride month
he puts out here's the reason biblically
why I believe Christians ought to be
boycotting Target and Bud Light and any
other Corporation that's pushing the
things they're pushing I think a lot of
people make this into a political issue
or they say oh what's the big deal if
you know is it really going to make that
big of a difference if I'm shopping
there or not shopping there here's what
the Bible says it tells us what to do as
Christians in Ephesians chapter five it
says this take no part in the unfruitful
works of darkness but instead expose
them for a shameful to even talk of the
things that they do in secret so what
does that mean to take no part well
what's Target do it's a business they
they make money they sell things and
they take part in that is to take part
in that God of Mammon that they're
serving and take part in the darkness
that they're purveying and getting out
to the world and and shoving into
children's faces and to take part in
that is to give them your money and I
believe the Bible gives us radical
precedent to say no we are running into
an extend instead expose those things to
to shout it to all the people that have
ears to hear that this is evil this is
demonic we won't stand for it we're not
going to go to the stories anymore and
we're not going to give them our money
we're going to let our voice be heard so
that people can see the light and so
that people can be pulled out of the
darkness
unless Blue Jays management calls me and
tells me to apologize in which case
never mind forget I posted it what's
amazing about that post is it's not just
some vague kind of hint that he doesn't
like the pride month displays this is
pretty clear this is pretty intense
stuff this guy this blue jay saw this
post and said oh that speaks to me and
I'm a Christian and I I believe in this
and so I'm going to post it out there
I'm really not disparaging this guy even
Saint Peter denied our Lord three times
before the grew
but
it's a reminder for all of us the
pressure is going to be very very
intense you're going to see it at your
job you're going to see it at school
you're going to see it with your friends
you're going to see in your neighborhood
you're going to see at your local coffee
shop it's going to be everywhere
we should all pray that we can stand
firm when that pressure comes down
because this is a very very intense
campaign we're only on day one of it I
know we've just had pre-pride month
you've seen the rainbows for a while now
in the same way that that shops start
marketing Valentine's Day starting in
December these days you you've been
seeing this for a while
you better pray that you can stand firm
here
because this is overtaking the culture
boy what a great clip that was make sure
that you ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel we'll
see you next time